um okay so question for the girls
have you ever lied about your body count
no actually never you've always told the
truth yeah has like I ever asked you
um
I think it's come up in conversation but
no one that I'm actually seeing No
actually that's a lie yeah they have
asked me but it's not like it wouldn't
be the first question okay maybe like a
couple months in and did you tell and
you told them the truth yeah yeah okay
what about you
yes you have lied yeah what did you tell
them it was
we did not speak but um
let's just say I said it was five but so
if body count doesn't matter why'd you
lie because
at the time
my ex was quite judgy and I thought it
would break up with me if you found out
how many people right did he believe you
no I told him at the end oh you told
them yeah yeah did he stay with you or
no yeah okay so he did accept it yeah
yeah I felt disappointed he was
disappointed yeah
well it is what it is okay what about
you so back in the day I did actually
used to lie I can't lie but now I'm very
open about it I don't care what people
think about me I'm very expressive but I
have lied in the past about my body
count but I'm not ashamed about it what
did you say it was
like 10 20 10 20. yeah and what do you
will you say what it is you seem open to
saying it if you want yeah I'll say it's
probably over a hundreds
maybe or 80 I don't know wow
I'm just wondering how do you go through
that and like how how do you meet a
hundred men you want to sleep with
I just enjoy life like I pray for a lot
of experiences I go on holiday I do all
these things and I'm just thinking why
should I care about what people think
you're just jealous you're living
because yeah you're not living my life
tell him again does it ruins your future
you know you're here for a fun time not
a long time yeah exactly well it really
we all die at some point in our life
yeah but boy that's not a way to think
about it bro what are we rude go for it
100 plus look let's say you meet a girl
of 100 plus that wouldn't be judgment
that one above you no 100 plus is like
yeah but that's that's normal like you
would out of all them people yeah I'm
not gonna lie right you know what I mean
what's the point I'm gonna be honest of
course no I appreciate you being honest
but I'm just thinking like
that's a hundred how like but there's so
many people out there that have got that
body count but they won't own up to it I
know plenty of people out there really
with that amount how common do you think
it is what percent of girls have slept
with that many people probably I even 60
to 70. I reckon
there's a lot out there but they just
won't own up to that you're just
experienced it's even better exactly I
don't care what people think and that's
why I'm in the place I am now because I
don't care but don't you think that you
should care about what the man you want
thinks yeah but I'm not in that right
headspace right now to care what that
man thinks because I'm enjoying my life
so you're focused on yourself yeah very
focused so when do you think you'll be
ready to focus on the man
maybe when I'm like 30. I'm 24 now so
that's six years that's six years for me
to enjoy it you gotta understand the way
you're living now I'm not judging you
I'm not judging you know
a lot of people you said like 100 plus
on average right
um all right so you tell me in six years
what would that be
yeah but what yeah when did you lose
your virginity I'm just like calculating
this per year 16
so 16 you said you're 24. it sounds
really bad me saying that that's just
average I'm not saying it was literally
over a hundred but like that has been a
lot of yeah it's been an estimate and I
have had a lot of experiences and I will
never regret how I am as a person and
how I even I am about it as well what's
the most people you've slept with in
like a week
probably only three or four
I think what do you mean only three
so I'm sorry I don't mean this is so
crazy to me and I know people could be
looking at me online and thinking oh
what a slag but people do this as a
living as well you've got to remember
that like just enjoy your life and be
who you are as a person and if you if
you like having sex all the time then go
and do it and be open about what you do
would it bother you if like the
consequence of that would be not being
able to get married later
yes I know because I do want to be my
wonder I want to have children so you
have to think about what the man wants
what I was yeah I'm a very selfish
person I want to enjoy my own life and I
don't think about things in the future I
just think about at the moment I'm in
right now
but I understand why I understand that
but I think that the goal for every
woman is to get buried and have children
and create a family one day right yeah
so I understand that you live in your
life you're enjoying yourself 100 I I
agree with that you should 100 do that
but I also think that you should think
about what the man that you want
is gonna think about a woman that has
such a high body but what if he was the
same as me though it's not the same like
we just spoke about that earlier about a
man having children men and women aren't
the same like men care about that stuff
women don't but I'll give you I'll give
you an example um would you would you
guys rather like I'm gonna ask you guys
the question would you rather have a
virgin or a guy who cheated on you or
cheated on his ex-girlfriend in the past
that was a tough one be honest bro be
honest what a guy that is a virgin yeah
a virgin you'd pick the Virgin over a
guy that cheated in the pick half a cap
but I'll take your wife
I would probably take the cheetah you
know yeah
experience have you ever dated a cheater
so you like cheaters on some level if
you keep dating us it seems like that's
my type yeah so that's upset you're
capping because you picked the cheaters
you're pretty girl you could date anyone
it's not like that what do you mean I
wish I wish they just treated me right
maybe maybe you like the ones that treat
you bad yeah I think so too I think
that's my type I really do think that's
my type yeah
but that's what I mean so you're not
picking the you're not picking the guys
that are virgins you like cheaters yeah
I'm I guess so but
I would like a man you know there's a
virgin and like man would you rather
have a girl that's a virgin or a girl
that cheated on her boyfriend in the
past a virgin
of course why is that even a question I
don't know you know I'm not gonna lie I
feel like
would do I don't know what do you mean
don't know bro just like just because
she's a virgin it's just I mean that
there's a lot of experience with someone
you like I've gone through so much
experience I've cheated I've been loyal
I've done a lot of things and
with someone who's a virgin I won't be
able to kind of communicate like that
with
yeah
hold on because you can create that
experience with her because if she's a
virgin she's more so she can cheat but
cheat on me no no no no no no no no
she's more likely to move to what you
want okay so if she's a virgin okay
she's more likely to please you the way
you want how many people are with the
very first people they've ever been with
are you as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible